I now want to read to you a tweet from
the Metropolitan Police this occurred
yesterday during uh this rally check
this out officers working as part of the
policing and Security operation for the
March against anti-Semitism have
arrested a 40-year-old man on the Strand
he refused to comply with a d a
direction to disperse under Section 35
of antisocial Behavior crime and
policing act now you might think this is
odd because we've been showing you weeks
and weeks of people calling for genocide
people you know vandalizing monuments
screaming at people breaking windows in
Jewish stores and nobody seems to be
arrested this is not only in London it's
in New York City and elsewhere but who
could this 40-year-old man be this is
very bizarre well I've got a tweet here
from Ian miles Chang he said the London
Metropolitan Police have a pre-crime
mandate just the potential of something
to cause offense is enough for them to
act but only when that something happens
to be Tommy Robinson two tiered policing
at its finest and now I'm going to show
you some video this is Tommy Robinson
I'll tell you a bit more about him in
just a moment uh being arrested at the
March against anti-Semitism now he's
he's a white guy he's British uh he has
been a defender of the Jewish people
even though people call him allright and
right right ring maniac and all that I
interviewed him he was one of the first
guys I interviewed on the Ruben report
back in I think 2015 if I'm not mistaken
here he is being uh even though he is a
supporter of Israel and the Jews in
London doing nothing uh illegal they
arrested him while he was having
breakfast they literally came up to the
restaurant he was waiting for his
breakfast to be uh delivered to the
table uh here they are arresting him at
the
rally
okay to be clear he did not do anything
he showed up at that rally to peacefully
uh you could say celebrate with those
people to talk about freedom and a
defense of not only Israel but obviously
of the UK and London specifically and
everything else they so I like what Ian
wrote there that this is pre- crime did
you guys see Minority Report like we're
starting to enter pre- crime what was
the line there that they said can you go
back on the on the prompter for just a
second what was the specific line in uh
that they arrested him for um under
Section 35 there it is section 35 of the
antisocial Behavior crime and policing
act antisocial Behavior I mean that
literally he was there having
breakfast to to protest peacefully with
those people now how about we do a
little compare and contrast could we do
that let's juxtapose some stuff here's a
video I think we showed you this one we
have so many of them uh here's a bunch
of people screaming crazy lunacy on the
Streets of London just over the past
couple
weeks it was terrifying the boys had to
be rescued by the police as bottles and
eggs rain down on
[Applause]
[Music]
them Muhammad hijab then threatened a
police officer that he'd killed the
boy's dog if he saw it again however
when the when those vist came in with
their dogs that wasn't
that was an act of provocation so what
we're saying now and I'm making it very
clear so everyone understands if those
dogs come close to us again we will see
it as an act of aggression and we will
kill those dogs we'll put them down
hijab and da then led the crowd to sp's
corner and as the mob marched through
London streets screaming we'll find some
Jews we want their blood the police did
nothing let that sink in they're calling
for our literal blood and the police are
just strolling alongside them we 5
there the
blood this is the n anti-jewish
Edition I think we all know who the good
guys and bad guys are here there's a
slim layer of people who are confused
about some of this stuff and then
there's a layer who use the people who
are confused for all of the wrong
reasons uh but of course nobody has been
arrested at any of these things the guy
threatening to kill the dog the people
calling for genocide they're throwing
eggs at the cops they're breaking
windows they're vandalizing monuments
nobody gets arrested there then one
British citizen shows up to have
breakfast at the March against
anti-Semitism and he's the bad
guy